[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL ANGERMANN:
Hello, everybody,
and welcome to this session
on the new Fused Location
Provider.
Thanks for joining us
here, in Mountain View,
and also folks on
the Livestream.
My name is Michael Angermann,
I'm a software engineer here,
at Google, right
across the street.
And my job is to improve
location on Android.
MARTIN FRASSL: Hello everyone.
My name is Martin, and
I'm, as well, a software
engineer in the Android location
team here, in Mountain View.
Thanks.
MICHAEL ANGERMANN: It's great
to see that so many of you
have so much interest
in good location.
And that's no surprise because
location is super important.
It is used in many amazing
apps, and all these apps
make our lives so much easier.
So I would like to ask
for a quick show of hands.
Many of you have traveled
to Mountain View,
and who of you has used Maps
this week to find your way?
I have.
OK, I see two people who
haven't, but everybody else
has.
That's great.
And who of you has used
a ride sharing app?
OK, that's a lot.
Who has actually exercised and
used to fitness up this week?
OK.
this is getting fewer.
But I think we see
location powers
all of these experiences, right?
And I know that I am
preaching to the choir
here, because most of
you probably showed up
because you carry responsibility
for building location
into your apps.
And I would like
to take a moment
and talk about one really
important service that
uses location.
And in contrast
to the other ones,
I really hope that none of
you had to use it recently.
But in fact, I think it is the
single most important service
that uses location.
And I'm talking about the
Android Emergency Location
Service, or ELS.
When you call 911, it's
critical for first responders
to know where you are.
But if you've ever done
it, it's really difficult
to describe your
location, especially when
you're a stressed.
So when we order
a ride share, we
don't have to
describe our location.
We just send it
off with the app,
and the car comes
to where we want it.
And that's obviously,
the solution
we would want for emergency
services, as well.
So it's very easy.
We send a location to
the emergency services
when we call in an emergency.
And it's exactly what ELS does.
It sends the location,
wire, HTTPS, or SMS.
ELS is already deployed
in 18 countries,
and it's growing very fast.
There is a really,
really good talk
that I would like to recommend.
It's happening at 230
today at stage one.
It's by the same team.
It's different speakers.
And I highly recommend to
watch it, it's really good.
So Android provides
a lot of choice
to developers, especially
when it comes to location.
You can choose to get location
from network location,
straight from GPS.
You can get it via location
manager, or the Fused Location
Provider.
And over the next 35
minutes, we will provide you
with all the background
that you need
to make a really informed
decision to what's
best for your app.
And in particular, we will
answer three questions.
First, what is good location?
Second, how do we and
Android make good location?
And third, and probably
most importantly,
how can you use that
location in your own apps?
Let's start with
the first question.
What is good location?
Well, that's easy, right?
It needs to be
accurate, obviously.
But it turns out it needs to be
a lot more than just accurate.
And choosing the right
source of location
is like choosing the
perfect wine that
goes with a good
menu in a restaurant.
And winemakers
work really, really
hard to make their
product better every year.
And we do the same
thing with location.
We really strive to
make location better
with every release.
And like winemakers,
we get really
happy if true connoisseurs
who know about it
appreciate that location.
And this is why
we want all of you
to be true connoisseurs
of location.
And have all the information
that you need to judge it,
and make the right
decision, so you can
build what best fits your app.
And we found these
four properties
that good locations should have.
I said it's not only accuracy,
but accurate is in there.
But the other ones
are equally important.
Smooth, ubiquitous, and instant.
And let me explain each one
of them in a bit more detail.
And let's start with accurate.
When people talk about
location, and pitch
a new sensor or new
algorithm, they often
give just one number.
They would say, our
accuracy is seven meters.
Our accuracy is 25 meters.
Or our accuracy is one meter.
But what does this
actually tell us?
Usually, this number is supposed
to reflect the typical error,
or distance between
reported and true location.
And we can use
statistical measures,
such as the mean or the
median of an distribution,
to compute a value
for that value.
And again, this number
tells us something
about the typical error, but
that's not the whole story.
You definitely want to
know how big the error can
get under difficult situations.
And that's captured by what
we call the tail error.
And depending on the specific
needs of your application,
that may even be more important
than the typical error.
And if you run your own
evaluations, of course,
you can look at an entire
era distribution like what's
shown in this diagram, here.
But in most cases,
typical entail error
can give you a
fairly good picture.
And just to quickly talk to what
we see in this illustration,
there are two
algorithms, a and b.
And a does really better
on this typical error,
but beat us better
on the tail error.
And again, it may depend
on the application,
what's best for you.
Smooth.
Good location is smooth.
Users don't jump, so
location shouldn't jump.
And it's really annoying to
see a blue dot crisscross
the screen.
And when it happens,
user complain about it.
And there are a few things
that can lead to jumps.
And in the previous slide,
I talked about accuracy.
And surprisingly,
there is a trade off
between accuracy and smoothness.
And chasing the
latest measurement
can actually improve
accuracy, but it can be
very detrimental to smoothness.
It can lead to jumps.
And that's what you see in
this example on the top.
The green line there, shows
the ground truth location.
And the red line
shows the output
of an algorithm that
aggressively chases the latest
measurement.
And we see how much it jumps.
This is not a
pleasant experience.
This is not what we want.
On the bottom, we see the
output of an algorithm that
puts more emphasis
on smoothness,
and it's a much
better experience.
It's just to show the
differences between these two.
Also, quickly, talk
about transitions,
because they are also a
major source of jumps.
And they come in various forms.
Users transition from
outdoors to indoors.
And we'll talk about
this a little bit
later, and maybe see what this
does to our input signals.
And users transition
from driving to walking.
Or they take their phone
from their pocket in hand.
These are all transitions
that we have to handle
and that we have
to perform well.
Next is ubiquitous.
And ubiquitous means definitely
coverage across space,
such as different countries,
regions or cities.
But it means more.
It's not only across space.
It's also across
different environments,
such as indoors or outdoors.
Type of movement.
Whether you're
moving using wheels,
or whether you moving
using your feet.
And the type of carry, such as
in hand, in pocket, in a purse,
or in a cup holder in a car.
And just think about an
example of ride sharing.
So we want to bring the
passenger and the driver
together, right?
And think how different
destinations are.
The driver is in there
car on wheels, outdoors,
with the phone on the dash.
And the passenger
is indoors, on foot,
and probably has the
phone in their pocket.
And location has to
work for both of them.
And I almost forgot,
we don't endorse
using a phone while
skateboarding, and please
wear a helmet.
The last property
of good location,
it needs to be instant.
And what do we mean by instant?
First, we mean no wait.
If you can see this orange
arrow that points on this map,
it points to a gray dot.
That's not a happy sight.
That means we haven't been
able to produce or compute
a good location, therefore,
we are showing a gray dot.
And a user needs
to wait for this,
or an app needs
to wait for this.
This is really not what we want.
So instant means we are able
to rapidly compute a location
and don't have to
show that gray dot.
Second, no lag.
And it's also super important.
Imagine if we had a
really good lake locator,
and it could produce the
most accurate location
while driving on a highway.
No error at all, but it would
always be five seconds late.
A lot of users would
miss their exits,
and they would be
really unhappy with us.
So good location also
needs to be on time.
OK, I think we now have
a really solid foundation
to evaluate good location.
And I do hope that thinking
along these four properties--
accurate, smooth,
ubiquitous, and instant--
comes in handy when you design
location into your apps.
And we now get to dive a
little bit deeper, and talk
about how we make good location
in the Fused Location Provider.
Android provides a long list
of really great sensors.
There are the radio based
ones that we see on the top,
such as GPS, Wi-Fi, or cell.
There are the national
sensors, such as Accel or Gyro
as well as Magnetometer
and a few others.
And each of these have
very unique properties.
Now, the question is, which one
should we use to make location?
Let's start with
the one on the top.
And in this list,
GPS is actually
the only one that
has been specifically
designed to provide location.
And GPS performs really great
outdoors, and in open sky
conditions.
But whenever a GPS signals are
blocked, such as in a building,
GPS performance suffers a lot.
So to show this, we
created this illustration.
What do we see here?
The blue line shows GPS
location accuracy over time.
And this would be a user
who starts outdoors,
and their accuracy from
GPS is really good.
That's that blue shaded
area on the left.
And then that user
enters a building--
that's that red shaded area--
and the location
accuracy from GPS
really drops, because
the signals are blocked.
There's not much GPS can do.
It drops really to the floor.
Some point, user exits that
building and the accuracy
gets back, and is
really nice again.
So we are really fine
outdoors, but we do
have a problem indoors, here.
Luckily, we can also
compute location from Wi-Fi.
And Wi-Fi shows really, the
exact opposite behavior of GPS.
Its quality is
really poor outdoors,
but it's surprisingly
good indoors.
And that's because this is where
a lot of Wi-Fi access points
are.
And this helps us to create that
really accurate Wi-Fi location.
So if we combine these two,
we get this orange curve.
And that's already much better.
It's really good.
Like, we have turned
a situation that
was really poor into
something that's much better.
But I'm sure you notice,
there's still this gap.
And unfortunately, this
gap is right at the moment
when this person
exits the building.
And this is when we would really
like to provide good guidance,
so we need a good
location for that.
And it turns out that we can
use inertial sensors named
the AccelGyro, plus
the Magnetometer,
to bridge that gap.
This is the screen
gap filler, here.
And I'm going to explain
that in a moment.
So let's look at
what this buys us.
We have turned of really
rough location experience
into actually good location
by combining multiple servers.
So the question that we ask
is really the wrong one.
It's not about which one to use,
but how to best combine them.
And the technical term for
this combination is fusion.
And this is obviously why
the Fused Location provider
is called the Fused
Location provider.
And we have two main
motivations to perform fusion.
First-- and that's
the most obvious one--
is to improve the quality.
So make it more accurate,
smooth, ubiquitous,
and instant.
But it's not the
only reason for it.
We have another
opportunity from Fusion,
and that's we can
improve the battery life.
How do we do this?
Well, fusion allows us to turn
off the sensors that are not
very effective in a situation.
Whoops, I'm sorry.
So in this particular
case, we would turn off
Wi-Fi while outdoors.
And we would turn
off GPS while being
indoors without any detrimental
effect to location quality.
And this saves us
a lot of battery.
Let's now look at how this
fusion happens in more detail.
Look at our census again.
And if you look at them closely,
we can petition them actually
into two domains.
One is a fast domain,
one is a slow domain.
So GPS, Wi-Fi, and cell provide
information only about once
every second, or even slower.
And that's what we
call the slow domain.
In contrast, to national
sensors and the Magnetometer
comes in much faster,
say, 100 times per second.
And that's why we call
this the fast domain.
So this partitioning allows
us to apply Bayesian fusion
algorithms that best
fit each domain.
And, of course, we can
perform a lot more operations
per measurement in
the slow domain,
and need to be really efficient
with every measurement
in the fast domain.
Together they form what we call
the Hybrid Bayesian fusion,
and that's the workhorse of the
new Fused Location Provider.
Talk a little bit about Bayesian
fusion algorithms in general.
So, typically, they perform
two steps or phases.
One is predict, one is update.
And ours is no different
in this regard.
Let's look at this illustration.
Everything starts
at initialization.
Say, from a really
good GPS measurement
as we head outdoors in
this example earlier.
And then we apply a model
and these fast measurements
to predict the user's movement.
In general, this will lead
to a growth of uncertainty.
And we see this here,
this blue dot just grows.
And after a few steps--
and that's to be
taken literally--
a new measurement
from Wi-Fi comes in,
and we use it to perform
this update step.
And we compare and correct
the hypothetical positions
from our prediction with
this new measurement.
And we get a more certain
location estimate.
And in general, this
is what happens.
An update step will
reduce the uncertainty.
And this is why this blue dot
shrinks in this illustration.
And then, after
this update, we're
back to the previous step.
And it's predicting, again,
from these fast sensors
and the uncertainty
grows again until we
get the next measurement.
And what's really
important about this is--
you will already see--
you really want this
uncertainty to grow very slowly.
That's critical.
And so being good
in this prediction
is a key to creating that
good location experience.
And we will dive
deeper into this now.
Because the key
to good prediction
is understanding locomotion,
and applying the right
models to each type.
So what is locomotion?
Locomotion is,
like, how we move.
And we touched upon it
a little bit earlier.
That could be on feet, when
we're walking or running.
Or it could be on wheels, like
in a car, a motorcycle, a bike,
a wheelchair, or the
skateboard that we saw.
A lot of people use location.
We always have to
deal with edge cases.
But for now, let's look
at a more typical, really
well-behaved pedestrian, me.
Because this is a very
common case for our users.
And so what we see
there, on the right--
and I explained this--
that's a top down, a bird's
eye view, of a walking user.
So copy me.
I'm going to the back
of the stage here.
And I got this blue shirt
for this talk, so this fits.
And so imagine a camera
looking at me from top down.
And I'm just walking
in this slight arc, OK?
This is me.
This is what's
shown on this slide.
And we will need this later,
so I had to introduce this.
And remember, we
said we need to be
able to predict the
motion between updates
from GPS and Wi-Fi.
And we can do this by
using a technique that's
called pedestrian dead
reckoning, or PDR.
It's a little bit
of a weird name,
but that's just the name it is.
And pedestrian dead reckoning
has two main ingredients.
First, is step detection.
Second, is direction
of movement.
So the first thing we need to
do is we need to detect steps.
And we can use
the accelerometers
in a phone to detect
basically, the shape
or bump caused by a step.
So you saw me walking--
I could exaggerate this--
and my phone goes up and down.
And you can see there's
an ad in the axel.
And fitness trackers
have been doing
this for a very long
time, very successfully.
In our case, it's a little
bit more challenging
because remember, we
talked about coverage.
So it's not only when I'm
holding this phone in my hand,
but it's also when this
is in my pocket, again,
or it's in my purse,
or in my backpack.
Has to work, as well.
Makes this problem a little
bit more challenging.
But let's focus on how we
get that change of direction,
because that's even
more challenging.
There is the obvious solution,
we use a compass, right?
And let's see how
well this works.
This is me holding a regular,
good compass in my hand, flat.
And just look at what
this compass does.
And I'm walking in a
straight line, here.
Thing moves 90 degrees.
180 degrees.
Goes back.
Does a 360 degree turn.
This is not a broken compass.
This is a really good compass.
What's broken is the magnetic
field in this environment.
That's our office building
that just has a lot of steel,
and steel influences
the magnetic field.
There's nothing that
a phone could do--
or there's nothing
wrong with your phone--
if it's compass shows the wrong
direction, or another direction
and you expect.
It just shows the direction
of the magnetic field.
That's what it's supposed to do.
So compass, alone, is not
going to fix this problem.
The compass, or the magnetic
sensor, is part of it.
But we need to combine
it with inertial sensors.
And using a national sensors to
compute what's called attitude,
is the same thing basically,
that's done in a spacecraft.
So in a spacecraft,
a guidance computer
needs to know how the
spacecraft is oriented in space.
So it has nothing to do with
its position, where it is.
It's only how it's oriented.
And figure this out over time.
And it's actually a really,
really hard problem.
And it's almost
literally rocket science.
So it's no surprise that the
team that drives this pod
has not only great software
engineers, but a lot
or areo astro engineers who
are really specialized in this.
So let's say they
do a perfect job,
and attitude is computed
as good as it can get.
We're still facing a problem.
We still have to deal
with multiple hypotheses.
And by now, you're used to
this top down view of me,
and I want to show
what's happening there.
So this is me.
Again, I have my phone
in my back pocket
and I'm going to
transition to this one,
because you see it a
little bit better there.
And I'm first, going to
take that path a, which
is this slight right turn.
And what happens there, is
my phone made a 90 degree
turn to the right.
I hope that's clear.
Phone was like this, and
then walked like this.
It was a 90 degree turn.
So that's possibly
an explanation
of what we saw on the sensors,
Michael that this right turn.
Another explanation
is Michael actually
didn't do a right turn.
I just walked straight, put the
phone to my ear, that's also
90 degree turn.
And we have to deal with these
two possible explanations
of what we see in the sensors.
And we actually have
to deal with a lot
more hypotheses
than just these two.
And this is what we do.
Yes, thank you.
Let's keep the video
there for a second.
What we see here, it's
again, a bird's eye view.
By now, you're used to it.
It's not just on me, it's
onto a building here,
in Mountain View.
It's just an office building.
And we see Martin actually,
on the parking lot.
This is where this blue dot is.
And there was a really
nice GPS fix out there.
And all these green
colored dots represent
hypotheses of where
Martin might be,
given that particular
measurement.
And what we will see is Martin
walks into this building,
and I will point out
what the GPS does.
Namely, it's going to
be stuck at the door.
You will see this when
we pause the video.
And let's see how this works.
Roll it, please.
Thank you.
So we switched to
just the building
outlines to make this
more clearly visible.
This blue line
shows the trajectory
that the location we
computed followed.
And if you can't stop
it again here, please.
Thank you.
So this large gray circle
is the GPS measurement.
If we look really closely--
and I apologize, it maybe
a little bit hard to see--
this small, gray dot that's
still stuck at the door.
So the GPS was not able
to get enough signal
to get a location
fixed that is correctly
inside of the building.
It's just stuck at the entrance.
And we have to deal with this.
And we do this, of
course, by using the PDR,
the pedestrian dead reckoning.
And we're using the strength
of the Wi-Fi signals in there.
So, if we continue this, please.
Resume the video, please.
We see how nicely
this trajectory
follows Martin's path.
This small deviation
in the middle
is actually in the hallway.
So this is precisely picked
up by this trajectory, OK?
Yeah, so we saw how we
computed this blue dot
from all these hypotheses.
And how this
surfaces to the user
is going to be shown
in the next video.
So let's-- one more time--
we see the same building,
and we took a video of
the blue dot as it shows
on Martin's phone.
And this is sped up by 10x, OK?
It's really amazing how
everything comes together,
here.
PDR, Wi-Fi, GPS tracking all
these multiple hypotheses
and attitude.
And the sped up video
is a really great way
to analyze this.
So we see how the transitions
happen from outdoors
to indoors.
How some jumps occur.
Of course, indoors,
that's really
accelerated, or exaggerated,
by this sped up.
Actually, can we see
it one more time?
Because I would like to point
out the nice transitions from
outdoors to indoors.
Thank you so much.
So that's from the parking lot.
And then we entered
the building,
and that goes really smoothly.
This was this small
turn that we had.
Goes well.
And again, this building has
no dedicated infrastructure.
No surveys have been
taken there or anything.
This is just organic location,
as you will get it in there.
So--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
So a lot of engineers
did a lot of work there.
And the really good thing
is, you don't have to do it.
Because Martin, now, is going
to tell you how to use it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARTIN FRASSL:
Thank you, Michael.
Hey, you heard a lot on how the
Fused Location Provider works
under the hood, and what it
takes to get a good location
estimate.
We barely scratched the
surface, but you can already
get a sense that building
all this takes a lot of work.
The good news is,
everything that you just saw
is readily available,
and super easy to use.
We do all the
underlying work for you,
and you can easily access it
via the Fused Location Provider
API.
But we're not only
working on the algorithms.
We also perform
extensive testing
to make sure that
good location is
available across device
types, and at different places
around the world.
You can imagine that the
environment in downtown Tokyo--
maybe in a subway station--
is very different from
downtown Mountain View.
Yeah, here, in
On the image to the right, you
can see one of the many driving
tests that we perform.
And a big shout
out to this place,
to our testing teams around the
world who make this possible.
One of the best parts of
using the Fused Location
Provider in your application
is that you can continually
take advantage of the
improvements that Google makes,
both in hardware adoption
and algorithmic improvements.
These improvements become
active in your apps
without any code change, just
via updates of the Google Play
services.
It just gets better and
better automatically.
Next, we will talk about how to
use the Fused Location Provider
API.
So today's bike to
work day, and you
might have noticed lots
of Googler's rolling
in the morning.
And to make it even
more fun, let's
build a simple app that
celebrates us every time
that we passed half a mile.
And let's switch
gears a little bit,
and dive into an
actual code example.
First, we need to make
location available to our app
by requesting the necessary
permissions in the manifest.
In this case, we used
ACCESS_FINE_LOCATION,
as we require high
accuracy location
to determine the travel
distance on the trail.
Keep in mind, you should only
request the location accuracy
that is required
for your use case.
A weather app, for
example, should already
get sufficient information by
using ACCESS_COURSE_LOCATION
here, in the manifest.
Next, we get an instance of the
Fused Location Provider Client,
which is our main point of
interaction with the Fused
Location Provider.
We then, create a
location request
to define the characteristics
of how often we
want to receive locations, and
what the priorities should be.
One dimension that we haven't
talked much about yet is power.
While we try to use as
little power as possible
when designing our algorithms,
estimating a location procedure
requires power to run
the sensors and radios,
and to perform the
necessary calculations.
This means that is also in
your hands as app developers
to effect on how much
power is used by your app
when it is using location.
So let me highlight these
two lines, which can strongly
affect how much power is used.
In the first line, setInterval
defines how often our app wants
to receive location updates.
This obviously,
determines how often
the location is calculated.
So the higher this number, the
better in terms of power usage.
In our example, we used
5,000 milliseconds,
or five seconds, which is
actually a pretty fast rate.
You might set it to 500
seconds or even longer
for your use case.
In the second line,
we set the priority
of the location request.
PRIORITY_HIGH_ACCURACY
means that we
request the best
possible location, using
all sensors that are available.
The opposite value would
be PRIORITY_NO_POWER,
which only receives
locations that
are already available on the
system for other purposes.
So again, by setting
these two values,
you can influence
how much power is
used for location computation.
In the next step, we
define what to do when
a new location is received.
For this, we create a new
LocationCallback object,
and override the
onLocationResult method.
Once we receive a
location callback
we update our travel
distance with it's
past another half mile.
Once we cross this threshold, we
play Hooray to notify the user,
and push them over
the next half mile.
The last two methods
are obviously
not part of the Fused
Location Provider API,
but have to be implemented
specifically for our app.
Now, we put everything together.
When our app is
resuming, we start
to receive locations via the
startLocationUpdates method.
In that method, we
request location updates
using the objects
that we just created.
The locationRequest, which
defines the characteristics
of our request.
And the Callback object
that defines what
to do with the new location.
Finally, we want to
stop location requests
if the app is not used anymore.
If onPause is called,
you stop location updates
by removing them from the
Fused Location Client.
So these were the
basic steps that I
needed to use Fused
Location Provider API.
Those of you who are already
using the Fused Location
Provider probably noticed
that there are no API changes.
The improvements that we
made are all under the hood,
and have not affected the API.
There are some changes though,
to the location permissions
in Android Q,
especially for apps
that access location
in the background.
And you can find
more information
in the session Updating Your
Apps for Location Permission
Changes in Android Q. It
already took place yesterday,
but you will find a
recording on YouTube.
I mentioned it earlier,
already in this session,
any updates to the
Fused Location Provider
will automatically be
available to your apps.
Here's a list of the major
sources of location quality
that we plan to add
in the near future.
First, we will, of
course, continuously
improve the underlying
algorithms and models
that are used in
the location engine
to improve the
quality of location
and reduce the amount of
power that is consumed.
Second, we will apply
new improvements that
are made around satellite
navigation systems,
and make use of the
availability of monument data
from the chipset.
Of course, there's
not only GPS, but also
other global navigation
satellite systems--
abbreviated, GNSS-- like
Galileo, Glonass, or Beidou.
These multiple
constellations are already
supported by newer phones.
And with a growing
number of satellites
that are on view at
a given location,
the quality of satellite
based location information
gets better.
The third major improvement is
Wi-Fi round trip time, or RTT.
Wi-Fi RTT is a new
technology that is already
supported by the
Android platform
since the launch of
API 28 last year.
As the name says,
RTT uses the time
that a radio signal travels
between a fixed axis
point and a mobile device.
This time is used to determine
the distance between the two,
and from that location
can be derived.
This is very similar to how
satellite navigation systems
work today, and provides much
better accuracy than existing
Wi-Fi localization systems,
which are based on the received
signal strength.
With more and more access points
supporting the RTT protocol--
for example, when rolling
out the new 802.11ax high
performance standard-- its
availability will increase over
time.
To recap, here, the
main points, again,
that we talked about
in this session.
First, we looked into what
makes a good location,
and introduced the four
dimensions of accurate, smooth,
ubiquitous, and
instant location.
Second, we took a peek into
how we-- and the Android team--
actually compute a
location on device.
And saw some of
the components that
run under the hood of the
Fused Location provider.
Third, we looked into how you
can benefit from our work,
and use the Fused Location
Provider in your app
by preserving battery life.
That's all that we have today.
You can find more information
in the Developer Documentation
at developers.google.com,
which is
helpful tips around the
usage of Location APIs.
If you have any
questions that do
you want to ask us
personally, we'll
be outside of the
tent to your left.
And as already mentioned,
there is a talk
on the Android
emergency location
servers at 2:30 today on stage
one, which we highly recommend.
Thank you very much.
And carry on building great
apps with the location.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]